Вітаю це програма Європа У фокусі я Лара
бабалола Ласкаво просимо на ефір на
італійському острові лампедузи оголосили
надзвичайний стан після того як тисячі
біженців емігрантів висадилися там
протягом декількох днів
Вони прибули на ненадійних суднах з
Африки переживши небезпечну подорож
через Середземне море місцева Влада не
очікувала такого напливу мігрантів і
каже що ситуація вийшла із під контролю
приймальні центри переповнені
Організації Об'єднаних Націй назвала
ситуацію критичною ЄС пообіцяв
підтримати Італію в боротьбі із
нелегальною міграцією
однак політика Євросоюзу щодо біженців
зараз викликає багато суперечок правий
уряд деталей закликає Брюссель не
допускати виїзду мігрантів і з Північної
Африки і перетину ними Середземного моря
до Європи прем'єр-міністрака Італії
заявила що має намір вжити негайних
надзвичайних заходів щоб впоратись із
напливом мігрантів Грецький острів
алесбас ще одна гаряча точка для
біженців емігрантів там також
переповнені табори і складні умови
Емануель ложанг прибув туди кілька
місяців тому він утік із південного
судану і попросив прихистку в Європі але
йому довелося довго чекати процес може
затягнутися на роки і все ж Емануель
знаходить можливості протистояти не
визначеності Емануель лоджонг випромінює
позитив це не завжди легко для тих хто
живе на лесбісі лоджанг працює
волонтером у громадському центрі пареа
на цьому грецькому острові який уже
багато років залишається гарячою точкою
для біженців центром тут керуються
неурядові організації лоджонг допомагає
з безпекою як тут під час обіду і як
перекладача він із південного судану і
прибув на алес Бос 5 місяців тому
чоловік подав документи на отримання
прихисткою на переїзду іншої країни ЄС
Він знає що багато людей тут застрягають
у процесі отримання прихистку деякі
потрапляють у бюрократичну
невизначеність на роки
попри те що ЄС заявив нам що ефективні
швидкі та справедливі процедури надання
прихистку критично важливі найважча річ
з якою ми стикаємося у таборі це процес
у ньому вся проблема у тому щоб повністю
пройти цей процес надання прихистку у
нас немає іншого виходу нам нікуди йти
ми не можемо повернутися назад і не
можемо йти вперед поки не завершимо свій
процес
громадський центр знаходиться поруч із
міграційним табором на острові лесбос
для багатьох людей які застрягли на
цьому острові центри став прихистком і
рятівним колом тут вони можуть прати
білизну Навчатися або просто відпочивати
[музика]
робота в його команді надала життю
еммануеля на лесбосі певної структури та
мети
раніше я просто сидів у таборі нічого не
роблячи і тому почав відчувати сильний
стрес адже зранку до вечора мені нікуди
йти І нічого робити
з того часу як я приєднався до команди і
почав тут працювати я знайшов себе мені
комфортно і я навіть щасливий при цьому
опівденному судані 27-річний хлопець
вивчав політологію він хотів формувати
майбутнє своєї країни після тривалої
Громадянської війни і працював в
опозиційній партії та як антикорупційний
активіст за його словами це наражало
його на небезпеку Він вважає за краще не
розповідати подробиць
якщо у вас виникне якесь непорозуміння з
кимось із представників влади ви одразу
ж станете мішеню для нього і він зробить
з вами все що завгодно
вночі Ви не зможете спати Спокійно тому
що з вами може статися що завгодно
розумієте що завгодно може статися
Просто з нізвідки
Емануель ложанг вирішив покинути
Південний судан Він утік до Туреччини а
потім знайшов човен нелегальних
перевізників які переправили його через
Середземне море на острів лезбос літо
принесло сюди величезну хвилю нових
біженців офіційна статистика показує що
табір уже переповнений починаючи з липня
щомісяця сюди приїжджає понад 1300 осіб
що в чотири рази більше ніж раніше
грецька Влада відхилила наш запит на
доступ до табору заявивши що в них зараз
занадто багато роботи через масове
прибуття але неурядову організація
Європи небайдужа яка керує сусіднім
громадським центром стурбована тим що
ситуація на лесбосі може погіршитись
через велику кількість новоприбулих
кількість місць у таборі стає дедалі
меншою Вони почали використовувати
рупхали величезні намети люди живуть
разом у маленьких кімнатах де гігієнічні
умови набагато гірше ніж в інших
житлових приміщеннях і там немає
кондиціонерів вентиляторів тому
всередині також дуже спекотно
працівники організації повідомляють що
деяким біженцям у таборі не вистачає їжі
за їхніми словами щотижня понад 400
людей забирають продуктовий набори в
їхньому центрі у травні Міністерства
міграції Греції вирішило що табір більше
не годуватиме людей чиї запити на
отримання прихистку зараз не
розглядаються
це спосіб заохотити людей швидше
покинути табір щоб звільнити більше
місця для новоприбулих адже кількість
місць у таборі обмежена для нас
найголовніше дати відчуття спільноти
відчуття приналежності до людей дуже
важливо щоб вони відчували себе людьми і
бачили своє майбутнє у контексті який
змушує їх постійно відчувати себе
цифрами постійно відчувати що їхні права
не беруться до уваги що їхнє життя не
важливі їх просто описують як вторгнення
як потік як натовп як цифри але не як
справжніх людей
Еммануель лоджанг почав вчитися грати на
гітарі на лесбісі він сподівається якщо
отримає прихисток у Європі то зможе
продовжити здобувати освіту Можливо
навіть спробує піти в політику за
словами лоджанга Музика допомагає йому
не падати духом Він хоче щоб слова його
пісень давали розраду і відвагою його
колегам мігрантам усім тим хто застряг в
очікуванні прихистку в Європі
це означає що немає нічого постійного
Не думайте занадто багато на все прийде
свій час
тоді все буде добре
він безумовно намагається якнайкраще
впоратись зі своєю ситуацією звичайний
день у школі це те про що українська
школярка Луїза може тільки мріяти Вона
живе в Харкові другому за величиною в
місті України воно розташоване неподалік
від кордону з Росією Харків регулярно
потрапляє під обстріли і тому шкільні
заняття доводиться проводити під землею
уроки математики та правопису тепер
проходять у підземних приміщеннях цієї
станції метро незважаючи на такі складні
умови учні залюбки навчаються вчителі
зробили все можливе щоб перетворити
темні приміщення на затишні класи це
приємний перепочинок від реальності над
землею
Таємниця яка заворожувала покоління
легенда про лохнеське чудовисько
десятиліттями людина намагалися довести
його існування проте треба від
можливості побачити цю істоту щороку
приваблює понад півтора мільйона
туристів до цього шотландського
високогір'я Дейв халтон вірить що Нессі
існує але ви не знайдете його в груповій
пошуковій експедиції де віддає перевагу
пошукам наодинці він упевнений що цей
метод приведе його до зустрічі з цією
невловимою істотою
Ласкаво просимо на Батьківщину
найбільшої загадки Шотландії Лохнес
що ховається в його глибинах питання яке
хвилює покоління і приваблює мільйони
людей до його темних і каламутних вод на
пошуки чудовиська
[музика]
Дейв халтон бачив багато мисливців
нанесі які приїжджали і від'їжджали він
вже проводить кожну хвилину коли може у
наметі тут на березі його власний
приватний куточок подалі від натовпу
Дейв вірить що там є якась істота істота
яку він сподівається Одного дня зустріти
звісно що так Воно повинно бути так десь
там
Сподіваюся він Або вона досі тут у ті
ранки коли туман висить прямо над водою
ви знаєте Ну ж бо висунь голову випливе
і дай на тебе подивитися
саме пристрасть до природи уперше
привела дейва на це озеро тепер у свої
60 років він каже що залежний
зачарований його величчю захоплений
нескінченними обіцянками таємниць Які ще
належать розкрити
Це просто вони затягує волосся на
потилиці все є дибки Це дивовижно Я
просто це обожнюю
за межами відокремленого куточка дейва
Нессі став світовою сенсацією він
породив величезну туристичну індустрію
новий масштабне полювання на монстра
цього літа знову привертає увагу всього
світу до Шотландії
Якщо у вас є дрони піднімайте їх ваші
камери виймайте їх біноклі монокуляри
вперед
човен обладнаний ехолотом і акустичною
технікою обстежує води в найбільшій за
останні 50 років на дводній пошукові
експедиції сотні волонтерів залучили до
озера Лохнес
ми їхали 12 годин потягом вона тут і ми
її знайдемо
Ребека та її двоє синів приїхали аж
ізуельсу щоб втілити фантазію про несів
реальність ми приїхали тому що останні
два роки руфус мріяв потрапити на озеро
лохнесе спробувати відшукати Чудовисько
і я подумала що повинна зробити це для
нього
у мене не буде Іншого шансу В його
дитинстві я маю це зробити і ось 11 із
половиною години поїзд і ми тут а воно
того варте
і ще один не сінтузіаст потрапив на
гачок чергові пошуки закінчуються так і
не розгаданою таємницею але в цій
історії є магія яку не може загасити
невловимість монстра магія яка змушує
навіть найзапекліших циніків блукати
цими водами і задаватися питанням А що
якщо А для організатора пошуків Аллана
маккена зберегти цю легенду для
наступних поколінь навіть важливіше ніж
знайти саме чудовисько Я не хочу щоб це
зникло Я завжди любив цю таємницю і цю
місцевість коли був маленьким хлопчиком
мене Можливо назвуть егоїстом за це він
роздмухується зради власних інтересів
ваша правда я роблю це для себе Я люблю
це місце і справді щасливий що можу
відігравати хоч якусь маленьку роль у
цій важливій спадщині
по той бік води Дейв знову відчалює лише
він і його байдарка він сподівається
побачити з найкращої перспективи істоту
яка зазвичай цурається натовпу
коли всі ці люди підуть я все що буду
тут і зможу вийти веслувати до скочу на
самоті Ну і просто ніколи не знаєш що
може статися
[музика]
де є влюбиться озеро не лише через
монстра але якщо він зустріне його на
своєму шляху це буде справді дещо
особливе
[музика]
на мальовничому узбережжі Середземного
моря На півдні Італії назріває загроза
жителі неаполітанської затоки залежать
від милості везувію У сусідньому
передмісті поц-олі розташовані
флорейські поля величезна територія де
вирує вулканічна активність Можливо вони
не такі відомі як Везувій але становлять
значну загрозу
цей смолох ніколи Олександр піну
занепокоєний зростанням тиску підземної
поверхнею а мешканців попереджають щоб
Вони готувалися до найгіршого сценарію
розвитку подій
струмені сірчаної пари здіймаються в
небо поблизу Неаполя місто із три
мільйонним населенням балансує на краю
небезпечного супервулкану але це не
Везувій це флорейські поля площею 150
квадратних кілометрів цей смолох ніколи
Олександр піно знаходиться в поцуолі
передмісті Неаполя Він приїхав сюди щоб
дослідити що відбувається у Затоці може
здатися Що це Через відпливи низький
рівень води але це не так набережна
скелі навіть ціле місто усе підіймається
із моря
понад три кілометри земної кори які
піднялися більш ніж на метр
можете собі уявити який це тиск
у чому ж причина це підземний
супервулкан прямо під поверхнею
фолагрейських полів величезна кількість
магми і газів виштовхується вгору із
підземної кори
ми переходимо від еластичної фази до
нееластичної якщо я візьму гілочку і
зігну її вона спочатку буде виластичній
фазі коли вона згинається але якщо Я
продовжую її згинати Вона починає
тріщати я чую як вона тріщить
на флорейських полях гнеться земна кора
А вона також може тріснути як це сталося
під час землетрусу у березні 1970 року
перед цим земля піднялася майже на метри
як зараз у деяких районах температура
моря піднялася до понад 70 градусів за
Цельсієм місцеві жителі були стривожені
Учені з'їхалися з звідусіль аби
дослідити це явище цей цикл повторився у
1960-х роках і стався ще один землетрус
потім земля знову осіла але за останні
20 років земля знову почала підніматися
як сказав би піно палиця наближається до
точки зламу
це означає що земна кора ймовірно трісне
але це не обов'язково означає що на нас
чекає катастрофічне виверження Але така
вірогідність є
зараз земля вище ніж ми будь коли
фіксували ми приблизно на 10 см вище ніж
у 1984 році
Один зі сценаріїв полягає в тому що
низка менших землетрусів може дозволити
газон вийти і тиск знизиться земля знову
опуститься
другий сценарій катастрофічний тиск
виривається назовні одним величезним
виверженням спустошивши Неаполь і
околиці як місцеві жителі ставляться до
цих ризиків ми запитала нам у котла
reski та естраду далесіо які
переправляють туристів по
неаполітанській Затоці це безумовно
ризик але це також Прекрасна туристично
цікавинка тому що у нас є багато місць
де можна побачити вулканічну активність
зокрема і під нами на морському дні
філогрейські поля простягаються і сюди
бульбашки що піднімаються з гарячих
джерел свідчать про потужність
підземного супер вулкану
тут дуже гарно страх є але є і краса То
ж воно того варте
це дивно І трохи хвилююче завжди є ця
мінація де ла Морта коли знаєш що
будь-якої миті все може вибухнути
Ось чому сейсмолог Нікола Олександра
піну та вулканолог мауроді Віто пильно
стежать за вплив грецькими полями вони
стежать за активністю вулкана передаючи
дані у командний центр який у разі
надзвичайної ситуації попередить
населення
якщо наші прилади показують сильну або
часто сейсмічну активність ми
повідомляємо про це
вільна оборона сповіщається негайно А
повідомлення про тривогу розсилається
автоматично
і у нас є цей червоний телефон на столі
прямий зв'язок зі штаб-квартирою
італійського Департаменту цивільного
захисту
так ми можемо негайно повідомити про
великі землетрус
плани евакуації вже готові але
залишається питання чи спрацюють вони
такий вони пришлють автобус щоб забрати
нас там на горі
Якщо це станеться я не думаю що у нас
буде достатньо часу що втекти
якщо тільки попередження буде дійсно
завчасно
ой Перестаньте я залишуся
дуже гарне
люди на узбережжі неаполітанської затоки
люблять свій дім незважаючи на діючий
супервулкан унизу
Виступ на великій сцені вимагає
постійних тренувань справжнього таланту
і цей чотирилапий артист безумовно має
все необхідне Цей кокер-спаніель має
унікальний гавкіт Це особливий дар який
дав йому перевагу над конкурентами на
кастингу у Копенгагені з офіс отримав
місце у собачому тріо яке дебютувало на
сцені концертного залу і його власник
сподівається що виступ з офиса буде саме
таким яким він його вигавкав
навіть найвідоміші тенори що розпочинали
і публіка була просто в захваті а на
цьому Ми завершуємо цей випуск Європа У
фокусі більше історії ви знайдете на
нашому сайті Дякуємо за перегляд і до
зустрічі за тиждень
[музика]